People magazine yes it announced that
Blake Shelton was the sexiest man alive
yeah okay all right that's fine fine
whatever
okay good for him I guess yeah then
under here under readers choice
yeah they have they announced who gets
in the sexiest man award the best hair
that's right sexiest hair yeah look who
win yeah what were you cheering him for
you're at my show because my god is your
hair beat my hair that's fine hair for
this is like a this is a this is a
French pastry in a hat it is a
masterpiece it was the first thing that
I noticed when you walked in it is it
can move so come on
by the way also both of our foreheads
can move yeah I don't see that a lot in
LA you know you catch that we actually
can move right that's uh that was a
reader's vote so you should be mad at
your people out there serious because
you know hours of work go into this
thing every day because right this thing
bakes in a kiln yeah before I come out
okay I saw the the truck with the
hydraulics yeah I'm saying yeah anyway
in yeah it looks like you just roll out
of bed I do run your hands through it
and then sexiest hair that's it
ridiculous I love your hair so much
though and you know your hair morphs
through the hour of you doing your show
yeah I know that does it sort of it's
sort of like a mood ring yes and it's
sometimes when this when the energy is
down it sort of starts to droop I know
and then when a sexy actress comes on it
weird yeah yeah I know
and it starts you know undulating as it
is getting higher as we're talking
yes it is yeah yes it is so happy to
have you
you